it's good to be with you again here in
the midst of such turmoil and hate when
last i joined you the taliban was still
a far-off threat nancy pelosi was still
a legislative genius the media was still
ignoring the border chaos and joe biden
was still the kindly grandpa set on
returning unity and normalcy to the
nation
how quickly things seemed to change
but did any aspect of our situation
actually change or rather has the truth
about our failed leadership class simply
been revealed in stark moments of
clarity this week i want to take a step
back from the news of the moment to talk
to you about the depth of our problems
in america today i want to ask you this
question why are the very things that
once united us now used to divide us
when did being a preach a preacher a
teacher a cop becomes something
politically charged and why who among us
wants that division to exist who
corrupted our institutions with these
lies who made this happen
the answer is more villainous than you
might suspect and more intentional than
you might think but we'll get to that a
new poll from the university of
virginia's center for politics found
that a shocking number of americans are
so fed up with division that they want
for lack of a better term
a national divorce a breakup of red and
blue states their poll found 41 percent
of biden voters and 52 percent of trump
voters favor this separation
let's get one thing straight that's not
happening it's not a thing that we will
do
federalism exists for a reason to allow
very different americans with very
different priorities to live in a
country together what's more i'm
disappointed in any conservative who
seriously entertains such ideas did you
miss every lesson about the growing
backlash to leftist overreach we've seen
for decades
they're headed toward the exits white
knuckling it till the midterms barely
hanging on to power sending george soros
funded shouting children into the
bathroom to harass senator cinema and
you want to bow out now
that's loser talk
the left thought they were ascendant in
america that they would lead a
multi-ethnic coalition championing
critical race theory and police
defunding just waiting until the old
conservative voters died off you folks
on the wrong side of history they said
your time is over it's our time now get
on the right side of the ark or we riot
but they were wrong the black lives
matter defund the police and critical
race theory movements weaponized toward
our communities through the house of
lies known as america's public schools
backfired
where in the past the left played a game
of hiding their true aims this
generation of leftists couldn't keep
quiet about the radical nature of their
agenda they said they wanted to destroy
the nuclear family and we understood
they meant it
the problem is that most americans are
not motivated at all by what big
government socialists want them to
embrace
the american people are aspirational
they value work family neighborhood and
freedom
there are innate reasons most americans
are ashamed to be on welfare and food
stamps academic race hucksters demand we
all categorize according to grievance
but most americans would rather get
along with each other and teach their
children the same radical progressives
urge us to hate the cops or the military
or the border patrol as forces of
violence and colonialism instead we
honor and respect them the left tries to
turn you into a subject bending the knee
to their priorities in return for a life
managed by bureaucrats but most
americans still prefer the liberty and
responsibility of being a good citizen
the american flag is not something to
resent or burn or apologize for we don't
need a second national anthem old glory
is just fine for us
for most americans this is true we are
frustrated by what we see happening to
our nation but it is driven and fomented
by a loud leftist minority vastly
overrepresented in our leadership class
in corporate and social media in the
halls of academia and congress in
hollywood and silicon valley and i bet
in your hr department and we can't
afford to be quiet about it anymore we
must recognize who they are and send the
message you're not getting away with
this
free market capitalism is our friend in
this cause the old line against
corporate wokeness was that republicans
buy sneakers too
well more people who love this country
buy things than the people who hate it
if you want to stake the spending power
of millions of american families against
the horde of angry wokesters still
sharing apartments in bushwick be my
guest
there are more of us than there are of
you
what this will require of you your
family of all of us is an element of
courage which doesn't allow you to be
neutral you can't just throw your hands
up in the air and say i give up
it requires you to show up to do the
work to call out the corporations when
they run afoul of their customers and
the politicians when they ignore the
will of the people it requires you to
respond to woke swamp creatures like
clinton bagman terry mcauliffe who say
parents shouldn't decide what their kids
learn in school and remind him who's
really in charge
we don't work for you
you work for us you're a public servant
serve or get out of the way
it reminds me of a quote from captain
america inspired by mark twain about as
american as you can get
doesn't matter what the press says
doesn't matter what the politicians or
the mobs say it doesn't matter if the
whole country decides that something
wrong is something right this nation was
founded on one principle above all else
the requirement that we stand up for
what we believe no matter the odds or
the consequences when the mob and the
press and the whole world tell you to
move your job is to plant yourself like
a tree beside the river of truth and
tell the whole world no
you move
the answer to our division isn't to give
up on the american experiment it's to
fight and take it back it's to say to
the arrayed forces of the left you can't
have my country we built it we own it
it's ours and we intend to keep it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else